you must get recognized everywhere you
go Tom Bergeron well unless you're
wearing everyday clothes because let's
face it we've never seen you in anything
but a suit we grew up watching you on
America's Funniest Home Videos and now
you're the host of Dancing with the
Stars will you seriously wouldn't have
it any other way
being a contestant on Dancing with the
Stars might come off as a golden
opportunity when you're on the outside
looking in but dancers would beg to
differ with so many dark secrets lurking
behind the scenes it's a wonder
contestants managed to make it to the
finish line keep watching to find out if
the show is as scripted as the dances
are choreographed training is a
full-time job when celebrities agreed to
become contestants on Dancing with the
Stars they agreed to work a second
full-time job contestants spend hundreds
of hours learning and perfecting their
routines which can put a damper on their
quality of life I'm balancing being on
the show doing like five to seven hour
rehearsals every day luckily they
receive plenty of compensation for their
efforts making their demanding schedules
worth it according to variety stars are
paid 125 thousand dollars for the first
two weeks of rehearsals and the pay
nearly doubles as the week's pile up
unfortunately only celebrities make this
much as professional dancers are
rewarded with significantly lower
paychecks injuries happen all the time
dancing might not seem like a dangerous
sport to those who've never given it a
go but anyone who dances professionally
will tell you otherwise every season
contestants upper injuries that range
from minor to serious and it felt like
my whole leg gave out and stopped
working stars like Bill Nye Tom DeLay
misty may-treanor and steve-o have all
had to stay out of the competition due
to having sustained injuries everyone is
exhausted at first glance every single
person on Dancing with the Stars comes
off as a bubbly and energetic
personality but their smiles are a
classic case of smoke and mirrors
because in reality everyone's exhausted
from the judges to the makeup artists to
the contestants judge Bruno has even
admitted to spending over 20 hours a
week in the air flying between the UK
in America to judge dancers on both
strictly coming to dance and Dancing
with the Stars
who knows got the tough call now that's
a schedule we wouldn't wish on our worst
enemies your body their canvas the
producers of the show called the shots
so that means that your body is their
canvas and they'll make it up as they
please the series goes through over five
gallons of spray tanner every single
season and a boatload of makeup to some
contestants have asked to bring in their
own makeup artist in the past but their
requests were denied I know the show's
producers are very serious when it comes
to how their dancers look on stage meet
your partner celebrities are used to
calling the shots but their opinion goes
out the window the second they sign the
Dancing with the Stars contract the
showrunner is responsible for generating
dance partners and everything from
height weight popularity and personality
are taken into account off-limits
celebrities producers aim to bring in
big-time celebrities to boost the show's
viewership but some celebrities are
strictly off limits like a Lister
Jennifer Aniston and former President
Bill Clinton but no matter how many
times they're invited to join the cast
their schedules simply don't allow it
dye to work well for Aniston
please professional dancers lose their
freedom the show just wouldn't be the
same without its vast repertoire of
professional dancers but being accepted
into the cast can actually prevent these
dancers from taking on outside roles
once a dancer is signed on EBC has a say
in what they can and cannot do outside
of the show I'm the boss
according to Julianne Hough ABC forbade
her from accepting a sitcom role on a
competitive Network costume designers
are stressed out
becoming a costume designer for Dancing
with the Stars may seem like a dream
come true but in reality it's super
stressful more often than not costumes
aren't finalized until an hour before
contestants take the stage which makes
getting costumes right the first time of
utmost importance
according to costume designers Daniela
Gershwin Tanner and Steven Lee they only
have half a day to complete each costume
rhinestones and all so I'm back there
cutting it right before he went on the
show must go on life is unpredictable
but the show must go on so if a
celebrity has an emergency or suffers an
injury I really didn't think I'd be
dancing tonight producers have a handful
of backup stars who are ready to take
their place these celebs must learn
choreographies and attend dress
rehearsals just in case they're called
upon last-minute everything is scripted
as it turns out everything about the
show is choreographed from the dances to
what celebrities are allowed to say on
air every dramatic moment is perfectly
crafted by show runners who know exactly
what the audience wants I'm not an
adversary okay I can't help you if I
don't really know how you're feeling are
you a member of the things family hit
that big red subscribe button if you
haven't already if you're on your
desktop turn on those post notifications
but if you're using your mobile turn on
notifications on the YouTube settings
that's a wrap on the ten dark secrets
Dancing with the Stars doesn't want you
to know thanks for watching the things
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up we'll see you next time